Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David, you know, yesterday
I made a comment about Donald Trump continuing to
misunderstand how tariffs work, and I pointed out
when he says We collected tariffs from China.
No, we didn't. We actually collected tariffs
from the American companies buying Chinese
products, and this caller astutely points out that
there's actually another layer to that as well.
Speaker 6: You said the Chinese tariff on steel
is paid by the American company that uses steel,
which you failed to imagine is then that the
tariff is passed on to the consumer. So actually,
the consumer is paying that that tariff.
Speaker 1: That's exactly right. And so, you know,
this is I don't I genuinely don't know whether
Republicans understand this or they don't. I
don't think Trump understands it. My guess is some
Republicans get it, but they need it. They realize
they need to get in line and say, we collected
tariffs from China. The way it works is Trump put
these tariffs in place to try to punish China.
Let's just take an imaginary product. Let's
say it's, you know, steel for building a car,
OK? Company says we're going to buy our steel
from China. You put a tariff on Chinese steel.
China doesn't pay it. The company, if you imagine
that for each car, you need a thousand dollars
of steel just to make the numbers easy. China
still gets their thousand dollars, but then the
U.S. government gets if it's a 10 percent tariff,
they get $100 from the American automaker. So the
automaker is paying for that steel. But the caller
points out something that's important, which is
OK. Initially, the company pays the extra $100,
but then they just raised the price of the car
by $100, and it is the consumer in the end. So
Trump brags about we collected tariffs from China.
Really, you collected tariffs from the American
companies buying Chinese products, which they
passed on to the American consumer. You collected
in reality the tariffs from the American consumer,
not from China. And I don't think Trump
understands that. But there are certainly
Republicans who do understand it, but they pretend
not to, because that's just the talking point.
We got the tariff money from China. Good, good
voicemail pointing out how that actually works
on the bonus show today. Speaking of prices,
we're going to talk about, it's not just
home prices that are sky high. Rent prices are as
well, which makes sense when the price of the home
goes up. The homeowner who rents the place will
charge more for rent. That makes perfect sense.
We'll talk about it. We're going to talk about
the $73 million verdict reached with Remington by
the Sandy Hook families. Huge legal consequences
to that. And we are also going to talk about the
continued drama with Alec Baldwin after allegedly
shooting and killing of cinematographer. The
family of the cinematographer Zerlina Hutchins is
now suing Alec Baldwin. We're going to talk about
that. We'll talk about Alec Baldwin, Baldwin cell
phone, and there's a lot of I'm going to start to
say strange things going on here. All of those
stories and more on today's bonus show. Sign up
at join Packman dot com to get instant access.
Unidentified: And we will speak to you that.